je vis dans vingt mètres carrés avec ma
copine elle fait du télétravail du coup
je peux rien faire sans la déranger
comment m'occuper silencieusement à
maman chérie battue va devoir reprendre
la lecture ou bien sinon il ya le truc
c'est que tu achètes un casque en fin
août et ses deux sites un casque chez
toi pour la télé tout ça tu m'as casse
voilà ça s'est ouvert aux biens sur
l'ordi tu m'as casse mais c'est vrai que
si tu es à cette heure vingt mètres
carrés et ta meuf i-tele travail ça doit
être une grosse danas ouais je sais ça
ça fait gaffe à saint ségal face à te
laisse pas bouffer te laisse pas bouffer
mon chien je te le dis oui non mais il a
le droit quand même de sortir de temps
en temps à les faire une ou deux fois le
tour de pâté de maisons respirer l'air
je rappelle que c'est pas interdit
on demande de palme multipliées mais ce
n'est pas interdit et ça lui fera du
bien de temps en temps mais c'est une
vraie question il ya beaucoup de gens
qui sont dans cette situation et à
christiane qui me dit parce qu'il ya des
questions de de santé des questions de
vie pratique
voilà y'a christiane qui me demandent
cyril j'ai accueilli mon fils et sa
copine chez moi elle se croit à l'hôtel
comment la remettre en place sans vexer
mon fils alors je pense ma chérie que tu
dois en parler d'abord à ton fils
c'est à dire que tu dis à ton fils ouais
c'est pas comment elle s'appelle par
exemple nathalie faudrait que tu dises
anat voilà qu'elle lève le pied sur les
serviettes par terre sur les assiettes
tellement j'ai pu après cela elle fait
rien est ce que tu peux pas lui demander
de m'aider un peu je pense qu'il faut
que tu passes par ton fils ton fils le
prendra pas mal tu dis voilà c'est pas
parce que je n'aime pas aux caisses mais
sait il lui va faire passer le message
je pense qu'il peut nier il faut qu'ils
lui disent que ça vienne pas que toi il
voit là ça serait bien que tu être un
peu maman voilà après si tu vois que ça
passe pas tu la vois tout seul tu vas
faire le tour du pâté de maison avec
elle tu dis voilà natu nathalie où
naquit je sais pas comment elle
s'appelle tu dis ma chérie voilà c'est
vrai que je suis très contente que tu
sois arrivé dans la maison voilà que tu
sois avec avec mon fichier mois mais
j'aimerais bien voilà que tu m'aides un
peu plus parce que c'est pas que c'est
compliqué pour moi et puis au moins ça
nous permettra de voile à 2
de partager des choses ensemble mais je
pense qu'elle peut bien le prendre passe
d'abord par ton fils si ça passe pas tu
parle directement
j'ai dit une connerie non non non on
n'intervient pas sur ce sujet tu connais
très bien merci les docteurs à les
questions nous sommes une famille de
quatre personnes avec une caravane
si on décide de prendre la route est-ce
que c'est considéré comme être en
confinement à ça c'est une bonne
question
ouais c'est une question mais a priori
normalement facile leur caravane c'est
pas leur domicile habituel non elle est
interdit d'aller de décider d'aller se
promener ou de partir en vacances même
si en caravane
si leurs caravanes c'est leur domicile
habituel ils peuvent évidemment
puisqu'elle est mobile si c'est pas leur
domicile habituel non d'accord voilà
donc voilà dans apparemment c'est une
caravane qu'ils ont plus donc c'est pas
j'ai des doutes à dia j'ai des doutes
sur la fidélité de vos copains mais je
me retrouve en confinement avec lui tu
penses que devrait lui en parler alors
si je peux me permettre c'est pas le
moment c'est pas le moment en plus cela
il en confinement je peux te dire il
peut pas bouger une oreille lauda donc à
mon avis il va arriver un moment où tu
vas pouvoir regarder
voilà ce qui fait si tu vois qu'il passe
des heures au téléphone dans les
toilettes ou si tu vois qu'il est
voilà je sais pas qui n'est pas tout le
temps avec toi c'est qu'un problème ma
chérie après je pense que c'est pas le
moment
t'imagines si non seulement vous êtes en
confinement et en plus tu te retrouves
avec lui et tu sais qu'il a une autre 9
et là ça va être un enfer franchement là
tu laisses passer on verra après voilà
et déjà voit si t'es bien avec lui parce
que ce confinement
déjà je vois que vous êtes juste me
fiancer des mariés voici ce confinement
se passe bien si tu vois qu'après ça se
passe bien et que tu es encore amoureuse
de lui après tu pourras essayé de mener
sa petite enquête pour l'instant et
c'est de passer le confident parce que
peut-être même toi tu vas classé lui et
tu vas dire au bout de au bout de quinze
vingts jours tu vas dire en fait je peux
plus supporter et en vrai c'est pas un
mec pour moi donc autant fais pas
d'histoires
voilà et si tu le tiff toujours essayé
de douala de faire une histoire avec lui
et ses devoirs voilà si ça peut tenir
on est d'accord je voudrais dire que
toutes ces questions c'est les questions
de tous les jours c'est la question que
les gens se posent et que c'est bien
qu'on puisse répondre quand on sait
répondre
j'adore ça si je suis un amoureux de des
gens merci recul